[Music]
let's just take a second to enjoy joe
petting his
yeah let's just be more japanese huh
he's not just mr miyagi over here
you gotta say it profitable you do that
confucius say
when the dick get hot
[Music]
then
happy times
yes that's not bad it's not one of his
best ones not what is
so uh
i'm excited about this one because uh
it's about another german dude what's
with german articles you know what i
mean go ahead and give it to us you
reading dirt spiegel over there
what the [ __ ] is that beagle or
newspaper you guys everyone knows that
i'm dumb dude
yeah me too i knew that it is good
yeah der spiegel my man me and steve so
a german gamer broke his neck while
wearing a vr headset
you get pretty intense with the vr
just like that
one more time one more time
i'll do it while petting the bonsai oh
craig
the best thing is the way so where we're
at right because
that we're all laughing if he did this
in a hospital full of neck neck breaking
victims
that's what i want to say
tonight
right it was like that was like
i tried to fist about people and i was
doing it
right he's the commissary editor we both
right oh my god
so a german gamer broke his neck while
we're in vr headset but not because he
fell over while playing and said doctors
claimed the 31 year old who played for
up to four hours each day suffered the
injury injury because of his repetitive
and intense movements he's weak
it's this game only for just dodging
stuff through the boxing game on that on
the vr it's very good actually it's
really fun actually it's really good it
feels like you're actually boxing so
medics damn you want shoulder to
shoulder oh
i'm waiting for my tryout that's what it
is i've been practicing medics say
repeated strenuous movements wore down
one of the vertebrae in his neck causing
it to finally crash
experts at the university of leipzig
hospital who treated the man believed
this is the world's first documented vr
related stress fracture did he did they
did they tell you what kind of game he
was playing no but the top comment said
i guess he couldn't beat saber
no he's watching porn yeah he's watching
for him bro beat saber you don't know
that game beat saber yes it's this one
right the most popular one yeah via the
oculus he's probably trying to duck
something because things happen like
they fly at you pretty i mean those
things are pretty heavy we're not in
like the futuristic age of vr yet we're
in like the analog version of vr if that
makes any type of sense those things are
like [ __ ] like eight pounds so get a
stronger neck but he's also wearing four
hours a day or did not want to do that
four hours a day is pretty crazy
these two guys probably got the thickest
necks in the room definitely yeah i
would say nick's getting kind of close
to you guys are some thick neck dudes
man
you're almost close you're you're almost
big head style but i'm weak i'm a very
small i'm a small petite like pro vr
guys but like fighters fighters like
work out their next stuff right yeah but
this is why yeah you do vr this this guy
should have a regular exercise routine
so this won't happen yeah he probably
looks like a vulture and [ __ ] yeah or
playlist
instead of doing four hours just go two
hours dude that headset sucks so much i
can't do four hours i can do one hour it
hurt it gives me marks on my face yeah i
never tried it it's quite fun i have one
and i can't even do it for more than
like 25 minutes you got 10 minutes wow
like you get motion sickness or yeah
because if you're if you're standing hot
you a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no i can't even play video games it's
like it's like one thing when you're
like in control of your own like
dimension and space yeah but when it's
like a vr thing where you have to like
sit down and kind of like turn around
and rotate around yourselves that gives
me motion sickness and then on top of it
when you are like wearing it for more
than [ __ ] five minutes yeah that
thing is heavy as [ __ ] you're just
falling forward the whole time because
it's so heavy in the front it's not like
it's counterbalanced with like a weight
in the back right it's just like top
heavy and you're like constantly trying
to like hold it in balance so 25 minutes
of porn that's all you can handle
you up [ __ ]
we are porn though you sit down first so
you can like look down look around and
stuff like that what if that's how he
really broke his neck he's a costume
but it's
him giving a [ __ ]
it's him giving a [ __ ] with the vr
he's sucking he's giving there's a
virtual dick i love dancing i love the
dance on dance vibes yeah yeah james is
going after dancers dude i love it what
do you play uh beat saber
wait a sec
it doesn't look like beat saber
anthony plays dick sucking games in vr
dude
it's like you're doing it and you're
doing it you're doing it more than you
would on a real dick it's like three two
one sucked
[Laughter]
up wow
[Laughter]
like oh no i'm not sucking any dick okay
get back on that dick
oh no mom
time extended
multiplier
what's the checkpoint
what's the checkpoint usually when you
like when he's about to come or whatever
when he's a thousand come on that's the
checkpoint yeah then after almost
finished like speed it up and then you
gotta go hard
double points double times the end of
the level he comes and then he's like
you might be husband material
will you marry me
that's high school
[Laughter]
i gotta get this game yo it's called
glory hole dude
always start with one dick glory holds
64. with the glory all stars and every
time you win by how many people you
[ __ ] come
glory homemade explosion
that's time attack that's what that game
after that motors cause
that's how he broke his neck double time
can we i can't believe does the jk
audience like this they actually love it
almost like i don't know why but
exclusively no we like this stuff this
show's for us
i can't believe anthony bought that
[ __ ] game huh
he downloaded it yes i downloaded it
then he installed it he bought the dlc
too dude it's hard to play like over 10
minutes you got sold on the demo huh
that's why i only last five minutes
was really good at it that's true so the
man went to the hospital
after experiencing sharp pain in his
shoulders while playing a game doctors
did not reveal what game he was playing
but said it required him to move his
body to rhythmic visual and musical
triggers
x-ray scans later revealed the man had
fractured his c7 neck vertebra which
sits near the base of the neck above the
shoulders usually associated with oral
sex
[Laughter]
fake dude
oh no
it's just gaming
it's just gaming i don't even where
where would you guys like this article
wait what about you c7 vertebrae
actually
is that the thoracic or jurassic
jurassic park
you know um i never really play like vr
at home always at the arcades but how do
you prevent from walking into [ __ ]
walls and [ __ ] what arcades have this
much vr no i bet they're like they'll be
like it'll be like an arena and then you
have like the headset and it's connected
to a cable yeah two-bit circus is cool
or like oh when you go with your arcade
dude come on as a kid so in the oculus
or whatever you have to like pave out
away yeah like pay about a space where
you're going to play
and as soon as you step out of that they
have small cameras on the outside so
that uh when you're setting it up like
you can actually see out like past your
vr and then you have handsets and then
you draw it with a [ __ ] like laser
pointer so you don't kick a coffee table
or something yeah but i mean there's
still a bunch of videos online of people
that like still like they'll get scared
from something and sprint and then run
into like fireplaces but don't
[Laughter]
so you don't even need to have your
mouth open during that head-giving game
because they don't register your mouth
did you guys see that hispanic grandma
that was like she was playing with it
and then she was going like this
and then the girl's like what are you
doing grandma she's like oh nothing she
takes the headset off
what was that side story no no it was
just cause i was just thinking about the
is it real is that i don't know what i
don't know
i don't know all right let's uh
track it off game on youtube the quick
uh vr fails just to make sure we
understand the scope of this thing i
want to see
[Music]
oh my god
oh
[ __ ] he has 16
jk reacts oh my god
damn that's how good the story and like
the visual effects it looks crazy in
there bro like when you get a good game
to play
it's pretty
[Music]
oh my god what does she do she hates the
camera
she's swung it
oh my god
yeah there's a bunch of these videos and
they're really i just love the idea of
someone asking hey you want to play some
vr porn and then you put it on and
that's what it is
you gotta try this game dude it's so
funny just a [ __ ] i think you just
why is it [ __ ] locked on my head
why am i so good at this why is it
multiplayer
it's weird why is it real dick i can
feel it
keep playing this isn't vr this is just
a cardboard hat
there's nothing in here what kind of
kind of thing is it
it's just it's just like 80s swimming
goggles they're not plugged into
anything
what are these called are you
remember those when you were yeah
who's the view mastermaster
[Music]
you